[Music]
listen up this young lady here is
running a marathon for bringing
awareness Hospital don't skip around
Estella and donate to a good cause I'm
gonna be there at the finish I play I'm
gonna make a big sign for you isn't show
up for anything and then he shows up it
was an explosion and he legs the gone
bro
welcome or is he good to be back door uh
talking to you what are you doing better
[Music]
try and make a hero out of me you need
to tell your family what's going on with
you I can't do this I can't I can't I
can't do it this is the first time
you're in this week and you had three
appointments you just have to show us
yes I showed up for you you remind me of
my son he died helping you made me feel
like I helped my son and for that I am
grateful you're grateful
[Music]
he showed the world that they can't
break us no matter what the hell they
doing there was this time in the
hospital but I just want to give up and
we'll look at that Boston strong and now
I just want to live
[Music]
I just want people to see how amazing my
son is I'm gonna walk I'm gonna walk
with you again someday
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]